Meditation is a great way to calm your
nerves and to get present. Speaking of
presents, see what I did there? I was
honored to be asked by the Headspace app
to produce a series of five short
podcast episodes for their podcast. I'm
Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business. Welcome to this
special episode of Think Fast, Talk
Smart the podcast. Today we're stitching
together the five episodes I did for
Headspace. Take a listen as I provide
specific advice on speaking anxiety
management, empathy through listening,
clarity through structure, audience
engagement, and presence.
The fear of speaking in front of others
is ubiquitous. It exists everywhere. In
every culture we've studied, we find it.
And we find that it develops at the same
time when kids first become teenagers,
that's when anxiety really begins to
spike.
Certainly for me.
When I was 14 years old, I was
instructed by my English teacher to give
a presentation on his behalf at a speech
contest. Every teacher in my school had
to nominate one student to go to this
contest and I was his choice.
The only advice he gave me was do
something that gets the audience
interested. So I showed up on an early
Saturday morning, cold outside into the
big large auditorium. My friends were
there.
The parents of my friends were there
judging this competition and the girl I
liked was even in the room.
I had decided to do a speech on the
martial arts. This was something I
thought that would be engaging.
I was so nervous about doing this speech
that I forgot to put on my special
martial arts pants, the ones that have a
little extra room. I did a karate kick
to start and I ripped my pants from
zipper to belt buckle.
Somehow I managed to get through that
presentation, but it was at that moment
that I became very interested in how
anxiety impacts our communication. And
over time, and with a lot of practice, I
was able to become much more comfortable
and confident in my communication, and
hopefully, I've helped lots of others do
the same.
Confidence in speaking comes from a lot
of practice and a lot of work. It's a
whole bunch of mini experiments that we
run.
Each of us has to find the techniques
that work for us to manage our anxiety,
and there are many of them.
For me, one of the big sources of my
anxiety was worrying about the future
consequences of my actions.
I was afraid people wouldn't support
what I was asking for. They might not
like what I had to say. All of these are
future thoughts, and the way to
counteract that, and what worked for me,
is to become very present-oriented.
Because by definition, if you're in the
moment, you're not worried about a
future negative outcome. So, the
question becomes, how do I get
present-oriented? And there are lots of
ways to do that.
Doing something physical can work. Take
a walk around the building. Actors and
actresses shake their body out. Athletes
listen to a song or a playlist, and that
gets them present-oriented.
Sometimes I've been known even to say
tongue twisters out loud. Not only does
saying a tongue twister force you to be
in the present moment in order to say it
right, but it also warms up your voice,
which is incredibly helpful. Because
many of us think we can go from silence
to brilliance in our communication
without warming up first. Any athlete,
any singer, any dancer will tell you,
you have to warm up first.
I distinctly remember a job interview as
I was approaching college, and I was
working on my anxiety management given
what happened to me in high school. And
I had walked into the room and I I felt
the anxiety. I did some deep breathing.
I said a tongue twister out loud before
the person came back. And when they came
back, I was in a much better place. The
interview actually went so well, they
made me the offer. And in the subsequent
year, I was actually the person who was
interviewing for a similar position to
what I had. So, I had actually switched
roles
as a result, I believe, of how confident
I was in that initial interview.
Anybody listening in has likely done
some meditation mindfulness and is very
familiar with this type of deep
breathing.
Interestingly, all of the magic happens
on the exhalation. Your heart rate slows
down. Your respiration rate slows down,
so you speak less quickly. The shakiness
that comes from adrenaline abates a bit.
So, as a way of closing today, I'd like
to invite everybody to take a deep
grounding breath. The goal here is to
have our exhale be twice as long as our
inhale. So, we're going to take a
three-count in and a six-count out. As
we do our inhale, we really want to be
distending our lower abdomen. I like to
joke it should feel like you feel after
a really good Thanksgiving dinner.
On the count of three, inhale slowly
through your nose. One,
two,
three,
your abdomen is fully distended. Let's
hold in that moment for a second here.
And now, let's exhale on a count of six.
We can exhale through the nose or mouth.
Six, five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
If you do that just two or three times,
you can really put yourself in a place
of calmness, stillness, and readiness
for your upcoming communication.
This week is all about mindful
communication. One of the most
transformative shifts we can make is
focusing less on what we say and more on
how we listen to what others say.
Today we'll explore why listening is
often harder than it seems, how it
impacts our relationships, and how
mindful presence can help us truly hear
others, connect to others, and build
lasting relationships.
Many of us don't listen as well as we
could.
There are many barriers to listening.
They all happen to start with the letter
P.
There's physical noise. Sometimes it's
hard to listen just because the
environment we're in is loud.
Another barrier to listening is
physiological.
What's going on in our bodies?
If you're tired,
if you're hungry, if you're hangry, if
you're nervous, it's really hard to
demonstrate the focusing required for
listening.
And finally, there's psychological
challenges and barriers that get in the
way of listening. A lot of us are
rehearsing what we want to say next.
We're judging, we're evaluating, we're
connecting ideas.
Listening is definitely a skill that we
can all develop. Believe me, my wife
encourages me all the time to keep
developing my listening skills.
We learn listening by observing others
and and see what works. And we also
learn listening by seeing how people
respond to us. It's not innate. We can
all learn to listen better.
To be a better listener, there are
several things you can do. I like to
teach my students how to ace their
listening: pace, space, and grace.
To begin, we have to give ourselves
space.
And I mean space in two ways. One, we
have to physically be in a place where
we can actually hear.
Maybe that means moving to a quieter
room, stepping outside, but more
importantly, we need to give ourselves
mental space. There's a lot going on in
our heads whenever we interact. We need
to open up a space to actually be
present and listen.
Beyond space, we have to slow the pace
down.
Life comes at us very quickly.
Interactions are fast. You need to slow
down and focus to allow you to truly
listen.
And then finally, you have to give
yourself some grace. And grace is all
about giving yourself permission, not
just to listen, but to listen beyond the
words. When people say things, I'll
share a story where I messed that up. I
came out of a meeting with a colleague
and he turned to me and he said, "How do
you think that went?" And our experience
in the meeting did not go well. It was
very poor.
And I immediately jumped into giving
feedback. I thought that's what he was
looking for.
In fact, had I noticed he came out the
back door, not the front door as I did.
He was looking down, he was speaking
more slowly. In that moment, he did not
want feedback. What he wanted was
support. I had not listened fully and
completely.
So, space, pace, grace
put you into a place where you can
actually ace your listening.
You're prime to do it.
Now, tactically, what do you do when you
listen?
I believe one of the best ways to listen
more deeply is to listen as if you were
going to paraphrase. Many of us when we
listen, we just listen enough to get the
top line of what somebody is saying. And
then we begin evaluating, judging,
getting distracted. When you listen to
paraphrase, that is to repeat back in
your own words what somebody has said,
you listen for the the line. You attune
in a way that you don't when you're not
listening to paraphrase. So, I teach my
students and I work on this myself to
listen for what is the bottom line. And
then really interestingly, by
paraphrasing, you show you care. And
it's been demonstrated in a lot of
research that when you paraphrase, you
begin to build trust. And trust is the
foundation of all relationships. I'm not
saying you have to paraphrase every
single thing somebody says.
But if I taking the time to paraphrase
some of what they say,
you actually show that you care, that
you heard them, and that you intensely
want to understand them.
One of the best ways I have learned to
practice listening
is at the end of an interaction, a
meeting, a conversation, listening to a
podcast episode,
ask yourself, what was that about and
how can I use that information?
This internal interrogation, essentially
an internal paraphrase, not only helps
you better understand the interaction
you just had, but you're training the
brain, you're laying down the neural
pathways to make your paraphrasing more
efficient. The more you practice
paraphrasing what you've heard, the
better off you will be when you actually
have to listen in a situation with
another person or other people.
So far we've talked about managing
anxiety and becoming more confident and
the power of listening.
Today I want to focus on how we can
bring clarity to what we say through
messaging and frameworks.
When we're put on the spot, it's easy to
ramble and lose track of our ideas. We
we often take our audience on a journey
of our discovery of what it is we want
to say as we're saying it.
But with simple structures and
frameworks like what, so what, now what,
we can guide our listeners and make our
messages stick.
When it comes to communicating, it can
be quite challenging to take all the
thoughts you have, as well as all the
input from the things you're seeing and
hearing, and really put together a
coherent argument. Many of us in these
situations just list and itemize
information. When you see presentations,
people just have a ton of bullet points.
Bullets kill. We're just not good at
remembering lists and itemizations.
Think about this. When you go to the
grocery store, how many items do you
need to buy before you write it down so
you don't forget?
Well, if you're like me, it's three.
We're not good at remembering those
things.
So, to help ourselves, we need to rely
on structure, a logical connection of
ideas. We all know structure. If you've
ever seen a television advertisement,
you've seen a structure. It's problem,
solution, benefit.
There's some issue challenge in the
world, the company's product or service
makes that better, fixes it, and then
you benefit in some way. I don't care if
you're selling cars, medicines, alcohol,
most ads follow that structure. When I
first started teaching, one of the big
challenges I had was to synthesize all
of the material that I wanted to get
across to my students so that they could
understand it. And the biggest mistake I
made is I just gave my students lots of
lists. List after list. Do this and then
this and then this, or you should think
about that and that and that. And while
the students were interested in what I
was saying, they couldn't remember it
all. It was overwhelming. They were
trying to take notes, and did this go
before that? Where does this come in?
How does that play out? I was doing them
a disservice by not helping them focus,
by organizing the content in a logical
way.
As I have evolved in my teaching, I was
able to better structure my materials so
that the students can now engage in the
content in a very different way.
My favorite structure in the entire
world is three simple questions. What?
So what? Now what? What? So what? Now
what?
What is the information that you're
sharing? Why is it important to the
person that I'm speaking to?
And then the now what is what comes
next. Structure is something you have to
practice. You have to practice putting
your ideas in the structure. Here's a
great way to do it. When you're done
learning something new, participating in
a meeting, listening to a podcast,
ask yourself, what was it about? Why is
it important to me? And what can I do
with this information?
Not only is this a form of paraphrasing,
which helps with listening, but this is
a way of yet again training your brain
to leverage a structure.
You're training your brain to respond,
so when you're in a situation, perhaps
one you're not prepared for, you can use
it fluidly and easily.
Today we're talking about engagement.
Too often people think engagement means
being flashy, funny, or performing.
But real engagement comes from
connection. From making your audience
feel like you're speaking to them, not
at them.
We'll explore why people lose attention,
how energy and presence make a
difference, and what small shifts, like
telling a story, asking a question,
changing your tone of voice, can
reignite curiosity. I believe attention
is the most precious commodity we have
in the world today. Our attention is
constantly being pulled in different
directions.
It's hard to get attention, but what's
even harder is engagement.
It is critical to get engagement because
when you do, you then truly can form the
connection that you want.
I'm often brought in to coach senior
leaders on how to be more engaging in
their communication. We've all been part
of those all-hands meetings or planning
meetings that just drone on and on.
They're full of lists and facts and
spreadsheets. And while that information
is essential and critical, it can be
delivered better. There's one situation
I was brought into where I was working
with a leader who was trying to
unveil a new strategy. And his strategy
had 14 pillars to it. Let me tell you,
that was the first warning sign.
What we did is we got rid of the 14
pillars. We found that they aligned
nicely with three key values the company
had. And with each value, we made sure
to have some kind of engaging point to
it. In one case, he told a story that
reflected the value. In another case, he
used an analogy that we could all relate
to. And then finally,
what he did was he had a participative
activity where he asked us each to think
about something and how that could be
reflected in what this particular
strategic idea was about. We took a very
boring, very dry, hard-to-understand
communication and made it interesting
and engaging.
When it comes to engagement, there are
four primary ways that you can do it.
One is by getting people physically
engaged. Where people's bodies go, their
brains will follow. So, tactics and
techniques might include taking a poll,
having people write something down,
sharing a video that they watch, turning
to somebody and having a conversation.
When you're virtual, it could be using
the chat, the reaction buttons, maybe
putting people in breakout rooms. Mental
engagement comes in a different variety.
We have lots of research from
neuroscience that says when you ask
somebody a question, their brain lights
up and activates in a way that it
doesn't when you just tell them things.
So, can you ask a question even if you
don't want a response?
The third is linguistic, language. If
you can refer to people by name or use
inclusive language like you, us, we,
that pulls people together. We've all
been trained since we were little kids
that when you hear your name or the word
you, that you should pay attention.
And finally, there is shared experience.
If you can lean into some common
experience, some common attitudes or
values people have, that connects us.
Now, there's another way to be engaging
as well, and that's your presence, how
you show up.
You can bring a lot of energy.
You can bring a calm subtleness. The
variation
in your presence, your tone, your
volume, your gestures, that variation
invites engagement. That's why I try to
vary my voice or my rate. That's why I
try to change the emotional tone. So, we
have things we can do with our messaging
and with our presence that are likely to
invite people in and be more engaged.
The other thing that we tend to do is we
tend to be very conversational in tone.
That's what really helps us feel close
to somebody.
If you can mirror that when you are in
front of a larger group, that helps you.
So, how do we do that? Well,
use conversational language. I once
coached a leader who was giving a big
talk at a conference, and as part of the
beginning, he said, "Knowledge workers
should blah blah blah." And I said, "Who
are you speaking to?" And he said,
"Knowledge workers." And I said, "Why
don't you just say you?
You is much more conversational."
A great way to practice being engaging
is to observe how others are engaging.
So, I'm going to give you all a
challenge. I would like for you for the
next few days to watch communicators
that you find really engaging. And ask
yourself what techniques are they using?
Are they doing something physical to get
people physically engaged? Are they
using stories or questions or analogies?
Are they using some kind of language to
really pull you in? Are they referring
to common ground? One of the best ways
to get good at communication in general,
but engagement in particular, is to
observe what others do and then begin to
incorporate some of that in your own
authentic way into your communication.
We're closing out this week of mindful
communication by talking about presence.
Presence is what allows us to manage our
nerves, listen deeply, craft clear
messages, and engage authentically. But
it's also what many of us struggle with.
It's how we use our body and our voice
to really emphasize what it is we're
saying.
Many of us focus so extensively on our
content, what we're saying, we want it
to land, we want it to be confident, we
want it to really help our audience,
that we forget to focus on how we are
delivering it. We are in our heads so
much that we don't think about what
people see.
That's our body, what people hear our
voices. So, what ends up happening is
people's presence is degraded by their
over focus on their content. Now, I am
certainly not saying that we should not
focus on our content. We absolutely
should. But, we also need to make sure
that we spend time practicing and
reflecting on how we show up. I have
helped many people with their physical
presence in lots of different ways. What
comes to mind right away is I was
working with someone who was relatively
new to their management position. They
had been a great individual contributor,
and they were promoted into a new role
where they really needed to exert
confidence and influence. So, we got rid
of the filler words, the ums, the ahs,
the likes, and I means by working on
their breathing. They would breathe very
shallow as they spoke. As they'd get
excited or nervous, they would breathe
in their upper chest.
And when you do that, there are times
where when you're done speaking, you
still have air in your chest. And what
often happens is as part of the exhale
to get that air out before you speak
again, you'll say a filler word. Try it
at home. Try saying the word um while
exhaling.
It's very easy. Now, try saying the word
um while inhaling.
Now, that's impossible. So, what we
trained and worked on with this person
was to end the sentences fully out of
breath
so that they couldn't say um, they
couldn't say anything.
They needed to take an inhalation, which
builds in a pause, which slowed them
down, and got rid of those filler words.
So, there are things that you can do to
reduce your filler words.
Now, this person also looked down when
they were speaking. So, by practicing
speaking while staring intently, they
became more comfortable with looking
more casually.
So, there's a lot of things that go into
presence. Filler words are one of them
that we need to reduce, and then looking
people in the eyes really does make a
difference when you speak.
When it comes to presence, we are not
the best judges of our presence. So, we
have to do a few things. One, we have to
solicit feedback. Go up to people and
just say, "What is one thing I can do to
make my presence stronger?"
Another thing that you must do, I
believe, to improve your presence is to
digitally record yourself.
You can do this when you're virtual. You
can do this when you're in-person live.
A great way to practice presence is to
record yourself and then watch it. Not
once, not twice, but three times. I make
all my students do this. They hate it,
but they love it because they learn so
much. After recording yourself
digitally, watch without sound.
Second, listen without video.
And then finally, watch both together. I
want you to pay attention not just to
the things you'd like to change, but pay
attention to the things that go well.
That's really important, too. All of us
have a strong presence, some of us
stronger than others, but we can find
things that we like and we should need
to lean into them and keep doing them.
And we find things that we need to
change.
I'm often asked how presence and
authenticity connect. It is absolutely
true that you should be authentic to
yourself and be who you are in your
communication.
That said, a large way that we establish
our authenticity is how we show up. So,
I never recommend that people be
disingenuous or do things that are phony
for themselves.
That said, really reflect on what's true
for you and how can you mirror and
demonstrate that in your presence. So,
if you're somebody who's really
passionate, maybe you'll speak a little
quicker than I might like, or you might
gesture faster. That's okay, as long as
it's being consistent with who you
really are. So, it starts by you
thinking about what's important to me.
What do I want to portray? And then do
so in a genuine, authentic way.
Thank you for joining us for this
special episode of Think Fast, Talk
Smart the podcast produced by the
Headspace podcast team. To learn more
about communication topics like these
and many more, please check out our past
episode library at fastersmarter.io.
Special thanks to Ryan Kempos, Katherine
Reed, and Podium Podcast Company for
bringing this episode to you. Please
find us on YouTube and wherever you get
your podcasts. Be sure to subscribe and
rate us. Also, follow us on LinkedIn,
TikTok, and Instagram. Please consider
joining our Think Fast, Talk Smart
learning community at
fastersmarter.io/learning.
You'll find video lessons, learning
quests, discussion boards, my AI coach,
and book club opportunities. Again,
that's fastersmarter.io/learning
to become part of our Think Fast, Talk
Smart learning community.